mon client monsieur Hardy voit une dame
au sol avec un couteau planté dans la
poitrine [__] je l'ai tué là mais vous
faites quoiz on se et l'individu qui
était à côté d'elle disait c'est un
accident c'est un
accident il faut partir il faut partir
c'est un
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
accident nous sommes le 31 décembre
1996 à Brison saint Innocent un petit
village savoyard situé au bord du lac du
Bourget tout près
[Musique]
d'exlbin il est 8h du matin le soleil se
lève à peine mais un homme se dirige
déjà vers son lieu de travail c'est
Daniel princic le jardinier d'une riche
veuve du village Anne-Marie Pignal 76
ans elle vit dans cette demeure située
un peu en retrait du village
le jardinier Daniel princique ouvre la
porte de la maison de sa patronne
Anne-Marie
[Musique]
Pignal et là entre l'entrée et la
cuisine il tombe sur le corps inanimé de
sa patronne qui git sur le dos un
couteau planté dans le torax à la région
du cœur en se rapprochant Daniel Prin
s'aperçoit que la septu n'est pas morte
son jardinier me demande si elle a eu un
si c'est un accident ou si elle a été
agressée elle ne répond pas
immédiatement le jardinier prévient les
secours quelques minutes plus tard à
8h20 les Pier arrivve à la Résidence
d'Anne-Marie
Pignal de la vieille dame est lent mais
elle ne semble pas avoir perdu beaucoup
de
sang les sauveteurs décident d'ailleurs
de ne pas retirer le couteau afin
d'éviter tout risque
d'hémorragie le couteau bougeit au
rythme des pulsations cardiaqu il était
juste collé contre le cœur anne-mie
Pignal toujours consciente est emmené
sur une
civière dans le véhicule qui l'a conduit
à l'hôpital les bombiers vont effuer une
transfusion sanguine pour lui permre
ouver une tension artérielle
[Musique]
correcte et la victime retrouve la force
de parler et voici ce qu'elle confie au
sauvteur j'attendais mon fils quelqu'un
a frappé à la porte je pensais que
c'était lui je ne me suis pas méfié j'ai
ouvert on m'a sauté dessus on m'a
attrapé le coup je ne pourrais pas
décrire mes agresseurs mais ils étaient
au moins
de 8h45 l'ambulance transportant
Anne-Marie Pignal arrive au centre
hospitalier de
Chambéry les médecins décident de
réaliser en urgence une ablation du
coumon gauche qui a été sévèrement
touchée seulement après 2 heur
d'intervention Anne-Marie Pignal décède
au bloc opératoire il est
10h42 au même moment à Brison
Saint-Innocent les gendarmes inspectent
la scène de Prim recherche d'empreinte
de trac ADN ou de tout autre indice
pouvant les conduire sur une piste ils
ne doivent pas perdre une seule
seconde les enquêtes en général elles se
gagnent ou elles se perdent dans les
premières heures la piste que
privilégient les enquêteurs est celle
d'un crime crapuleux il faut dire
qu'anneemarie Pignal était riche très
riche milliardaire même son défint marie
Félix Pignal n'était autre que le PDG
d'Itachi France un homme réputé pour sa
générosité la famille Pignal était très
honorablement connue à Brison
Saint-Innocent monsieur Pignal avant son
décès en 92 avait fait beaucoup de
choses pour la commune et en particulier
avait donné la somme de 1 million de
francs de l'époque pour
construire une résidence pour personnes
âgées cette résidence existe toujours et
porte toujours son nom et justement
cette richesse connue de tous a très
bien pu attirer des
convoitises la fortune de Madame Pignal
son train de vie la maison qu'elle
occupait attiré forcément des visiteurs
entre guillemets et depuis quelques mois
les forces de l'ordre sont confrontées à
une série de cambriolages envers les
retraités de la région c'est donc tout
naturellement la piste que vont
favoriser les enquêteurs précisément au
cours du dernier trimestre 96 il y a eu
un certain nombre d'agression de
personnes âgées et nous on s'est quand
même interrogé sur la similitude de hein
du du mode
d'agression pourtant lors de la
perquisition de la maison plusieurs
éléments étonnent les gendarmes
d'ailleurs le patron de l'enquête le
capitaine manuel nogera commence à
mettre en doute la thèse du
cambriolage il n'y a pas eu des
frraction aucune fouille n'est constatée
euh nous découvrons même sur sa table de
chevet une somme de 6000 francs en
espèce qui n'a pas été qui n'a pas été
dérobé les constatations réalisées dans
tout le reste de la maison toutes les
pièces démontre qu' n'a eu aucune
fouille ce qui a nous semble un peu
bizarre nous c'est c'est que rien n'est
été dérobé maintenant c'est vrai que
l'hypothèse que rien nétait dérobé et
que la personne a peut-être été dérangée
dérangé notamment par l'arrivée de
Monsieur prinx ce matin là faute
d'éléments les gendarmes écartent donc
la piste du vol qui a mal tourné et
partent à la recherche de nouveaux
indice autour d'Anne-Marie Pignal qui
pouvait lui en vouloir si ce n'est pas
un crime de reur qui pouvait en en
vouloir à Madame
piniè pour relancer l'enquête les
gendarmes misent beaucoup sur les
résultats des premières analyses
scientifiques mais une série de
négligence et de malchance va leur
compliquer la tâche il se trouve que il
y avait une madame Pignal qui était
mourante les secours sont arrivés c'est
normal on a essayé de sauver cette dame
qui était en train de malheureusement de
de mourir sous les yeux d'un grand
nombre de personnes mais on a pris
aucune précaution d'abord les enquêteurs
comptent sur les traces qu'onu forcément
laisser les agresseurs autour de la
maison il se trouve que ce 31 décembre
il avait neigé pas mal il y avait entre
2 et 5 cm autour de la maison de neige
pourtant contre toute attente ces traces
vont se révéler totalement
inexploitables la neige qui revêtait le
le le jardin de la maison était souiller
de toutes les empreunes de pas des
secours alors que normalement il y avait
les empreunes de pas de celui ou de ceux
qui étaient venus tuer madame Pignal les
gendarmes espèrent alors que l'expertise
de l'arme du crime leur permette d'en
savoir plus mais là encore en vain car
une fois retiré du thorax d'Anne-Marie
Pignal à l'hôpital le couteau a été
stérilisé on avait pas pris les
précautions fondamentales qui auraient
normalement dû préserver les éventuelles
traces sur le manche c'est une
négligence de la part de l'hôpital qui
ne savait pas que c'est une mais bon
quand on voit arriver quelqu'un avec un
couteau planté dans le dans le thorax on
doit bien se douter que c'est pas
forcément
accidentel donc il y a quelques
précautions qui doivent être prises bon
on avait peut-être AFF faire des
infirmiers ou une infirmière un peu trop
novice autre déception les experts
scientifiques ont trouvé un cheveux sur
une nappe saisie au domicile
d'Anne-Marie Pignal un cheveux qui
n'appartient pas à la victime mais les
procédures nont pas pas été respecté et
ce cheveux s'avère lui aussi
inexploitable de la même manière la
scène de crime n'ayant pas été protégée
aucune des empreintes digitales relevées
ne peut être utilisée sur la scène de de
crime il n'y a aucun indice matériel ou
aucune trace qui permette de
d'identifier le ou les auteurs de
l'agression seul indice fourni par
l'expertise balistique la taille de
l'agresseur une atteinte effectuée par
un agresseur de taille supérieure à sa
victime l'ennui C de Marie Pignal ne
mesurait qu'un,53 et donc son agresseur
ressemble forcément à monsieur tout le
monde pas de trace de pas pas
d'empreinte aucun ADN les enquêteurs ne
possèdent pas le moindre indice
l'affaire s'annonce particulièrement
difficile mais les résultats de
l'autopsie et les témoignages de
quelques voisins vont leur permettre de
reconstituer en partie les dernières
heures de la vie d'Anne Marie
Pignal
une chose est sûre la victime était
réveillée à l'ORS du crime une voisine
confirme avoir vu la lumière s'allumer
dans la maison d'anne-emarie Pignal
entre 7h et
7h15 comme à son habitude la victime a
ouvert ses volet et s'est
habillé enfin comme l'atteste l'autopsie
Anne-Marie a dû prendre son petit-
déjeuner personne n'a vu les agresseurs
mais le meurtre a forcément eu lieu
entre le réveil d'Anne-Marie Pignal et
l'arrivée de Daniel princic soit entre
7h et 8h du
matin les enquêteurs disposent de de
très peu d'éléments simplement une
petite plage horaire pendant laquelle le
crime a forcément été commis ultime
information pour les enquêteurs des
riverins ont entendu une voiture longer
la maison d'Anne-Marie Pignal vers
7h30 il y a eu une voisine et un voisin
également ils ont tous les deux bien
entendu une voiture venir le matin très
très tôt mais ils n'ont pas apporté
d'éléments tangibles pas de couleur de
voiture pas de marque et puis après plus
de
trace à cette étape de l'enquête les
gendarmes sont dans l'impasse on balaye
assez large toutes les toutes les pistes
possibles surtout quand on a aucun
élément aucun élément matériel à ce
moment là tout de suite à se mettre sous
la
dent parmi les suspects possibles Daniel
le jardinier après tout c'est lui qui a
découvert le
corps l'homme est interrogé et il va
faire une révélation à propos de l'arme
du
[Musique]
crime le jardinier quand il est
interrogé par les enquêteurs juste après
leur arrivée il connaî il va dire qu'il
connaît très bien l'arme du
crime il s'agit d'un couteau à pain et à
décongélation qui se trouve donc dans un
tiroir de la cuisine seulement le
jardinier semble dévasté par la mort de
la vieille dame il s'entendait très bien
avec elle et puis il a appelé les
secours alors qu'elle était encore en
vie rapidement les enquêteurs décident
de le mettre hors de cause le jardinier
était quelqu'un qui n'était un homme à
la personnalité tout à fait ordinaire au
bon sens du terme donc non il n'y a pas
eu de de recherche particulière fait
dans cette direction et il n'y avait
sans doute pas forcément faire les
enquêteurs ne dispose d'aucun indice
mais il leur reste une piste à exploiter
dans l'ambulance qu' a transporté à
l'hôpital Anne-Marie Pignal a eu le
temps de dire qu'elle attendait son
fils alors il est temps pour les
enquêteurs de s'intéresser de plus près
à
[Musique]
lui dans les jours qui suivent les gens
d'ARM auditionnent voisin ami et membre
de la famille d'anne-emarie Pignal il
s'intéresse plus particulièrement à ses
deux enfants euh sa fille d'abord qui
qui est une fille qu'elle a adopté en
1961 euh une fille qui est mariée qui a
elle-même des enfants qui vit simplement
c'est une femme sans histoire d'après
les éléments du dossier elle était
rigoureuse dans la gestion elle tenait
sa famille elle est tout à fait
normalement et il y avait pas de
difficulté elle avait de très bonne
relation avec sa mère sa mère la voyait
régulièrement elles s'entendent
parfaitement bien et euh leurs relations
ont toujours été au beau fixe du côté de
son frère HUG les choses sont plus
compliquées entre discothèque bar et
Casino depuis plusieurs années il mène
un train de vie bien au-dessus de ses
moyens oui c'était un personnage qui
aimait euh s'entourer de euh de gens de
la nuit qui qui sortaient énormément qui
dépensaient beaucoup HUG Pignal çatait
ça n'était pas un secret était quelqu'un
d'extrêmement dépensié il avait dépensé
des sommes fabuleuses il menait un train
de vie extravagant
il y avait une générosité
pour tout ce ce cercle amical c'est un
homme fort en gueule qui a qui a de la
gooua qui fréquente des gens pas
toujours très recommandables il il est
beaucoup dans les milieux de la nuit
dans les bars de nuit les discothèques
il fréquente beaucoup les milieux
interlopes de d'exlbain et des petits
voyou qui sont parfois connus de la
police seulement les gendarmes vont
découvrir que très dépensier n'est pas
sans conséquence HUG Pignal connait de
très gros problèmes d'argent il était au
moment d'ffet dans une situation
dramatique sur le plan financier il a
des emprunts qu'il n'a pas remboursé des
empruns à des particuliers qu'il a fait
des particuliers 60000 francs pour l'un
35000 francs pour
l'autre ses comptes personnels sont sont
sont largement débiteur il est interdit
de chquier tout comme ça tout comme ça
concubine ça paraî ça paraît fou depuis
2 ans HUG pinal est propriétaire d'un
club de squash à vivier du lac un petit
village sur les rive du lac du Bourget
mais le club est au bord de la faillite
au total pinal a accumulé près de 200000
francs de loyer de retard soit 30000 €
et ce n'est pas
tout il était très endetté à travers des
des pensions alimentaires qu'il devait
verser à ses deux premières femmes avec
qui il avait eu respectivement deux et
et et un enfant une situation financière
d'autant plus dure à expliquer qu'à la
mort de son père en
1992 le fils a touché 6 millions de
francs d'héritage près d'un million
d'euros une somme colossale qu' l' a
dilapidé en moins de 5 ans il flambe
d'ailleurs il nous l'a dit l'argent lui
lui brûle les doigts autant sa sœur
avait préservé cette somme en la plaçant
et en vivant en vivant des intérêts que
lui procuraient ces 6 millions de francs
euh lui h Pignal s'était empressé de les
dépenserment par la l'achat d'une maison
enfin la construction d'une maison à
punichatenau maison une maison une
maison de luxe des achats de de
véhicules de luxe he Porsche des
motos
bateau des voyages divers par exemple
après son deuxème divorce il va épouser
Viviane et il va emmener la quarantaine
de convives en Corse à porovquot pour
fêter le mariage et il va les emmener à
ses frais en avion en Corse monsieur
Félix
Pignal avait dit en parlant de son fils
de toute façon après moi il bouffera
tout en cette fin d'année 1996 HUG
Pignal a donc de gros problèmes d'argent
et pourtant les gendarmes vont découvrir
que l'un de ses comptes bancaires
s'élève à 12 millions de
francs problème il n'est pas le seul
titulaire de ce compte sa mère
Anne-Marie Pignal en conserve l'usufruit
et elle peut en disposer comme elle veut
en attendant sa mort HUG n'a donc qu'une
seule solution pour profiter de cet
argent obtenir l'accord de sa mère et le
moins que l'on puisse dire c'est qu'il
se montre
insistant quand elle voulait elle voyait
h Pignal il se fixait rendez-vous par
écrit ou par téléphone et elle notait le
rendez-vous elle prévenait le jardinier
chaque fois qu'elle avait rendez-vous
avec HUG Pignal il n'avait de sapprès de
harceler sa mère pour lui soutirer de
l'argent et elle avait déjà donné des
sommes fantastiques elle a régulièrement
éponger les dettes de de son fils même
si elle aurait souhaité ne pas le faire
pour pas que le le nom de Pignal soit S
par les dépenses et les ardoises que
laissait hucpignal un peu partout et
hucpignal ne supportait pas de devoir en
quelque sorte supplier sa mère pour
avoir de l'argent au fil du temps les
les relations entre la mère et le fils
deviennent de plus en plus
houleuses pour preuve cette lettre que
nous nous sommes procuré dataé du 6
janvier
1995 rédigé par anne-emarie à
l'attention de HUG bonjour HUG qui est
toujours mon
[Musique]
fils comment te rendre crédible alors
que tu cherches à ex à te faire passer
pour un cahide fortuné qui roule les
épaules je t'en prie continue pas ainsi
ni ton père ni moi ne t'avons donné un
tel exemple je compte encore sur toi et
t'embrasse maternellement ce qui n'excl
pas le désaveux de tes
attitudes une telle animosité
pourrait-elle justifier le
crime 3 janvier
1997 gendarmerie de Chambéry les
enquêteurs auditionnent HUG Pignal et
alors grande surprise dès les premières
minutes l'homme ne cache pas ses ennuits
bancaires
effectivement il nous confirme qu'il est
très dépensier qu'il devait qu'il devait
de l'argent et que grâce au compte il va
pouvoir il va pouvoir combler ses
dettes les gendarmes demandent ensuite à
H Pignal de détailler son emploi du
temps le jour du
meurtre quand les enquêteurs vont
l'interroger pour savoir où il était le
31 décembre
1996 au petit matin HUG Pignal n'hésite
pasug confirme qu'il avait bien
rendez-vous avec sa mère ce matin-là il
devait lui faire signer des papiers et
récupérer des cartons dans son garage il
était prévu qu'il passe chez elle entre
8h et 9h et voici ce qu'il dit avoir
fait
auparavant HUG Pignal se serait réveillé
à 7h dans sa maison située sur les
hauteurs d'exlbin il aurait pris sa
voiture un véhicule de type 205
commercial blanche pour se rendre dans
le centre lesbain avenue du Grand Port à
moins de 10 minutes de chez lui il se
serait d'abord arrêté à la boulangerie
pour acheter des pains au chocolat puis
à la Maison de la presse pour acheter le
journal d'ailleurs il aurait croisé une
connaissance un certain Stéphan
Chaban quelques instants après il aurait
pris un café au bar du
soleil il fait état d'une conversation
qu'il a entendu dans un bar où il a pris
un café donc il a comme ça un certain
nombre de il est capable de de de donner
un timing très précis de de cette
matinée enfin HUG Pignal serait rentré
chez lui vers 7h45 et se serait recouché
quelques
minutes son épouse Viviane le confirmera
au gendarme elle ajoutera d'ailleurs que
son mari aurait été réveillé par le coup
de téléphone paniqué de sa sœur
Hélène sa sœur
qui
indique que Madame Pignal
s'est blessé qui lui arrivait quelque
chose de grave voilà les gendarmes
décident de vérifier l'emploi du temps
duc Pignal il part à la rencontre
d'éventuels
[Musique]
témoins il fallait faire la lumière sur
sur les lieux où il s'était vraiment
rendu ce matin-là et et vérifier ses
alébis mais rapidement les enquêteurs
découvre que peu de personnes se
souviennent de la présence du Pignal au
matin du 31 décembre
ni la
boulangère ni le marchand de journaux ni
même le tenanci du bar du soleil ne sont
réellement certains de l'avoir vu toutes
ces déclarations sont sont très
contradictoires chaque fois qu'il dit
quelque chose il y a quelqu'un pour
intervenir pour dire le contraire
pourtant un homme confirme avoir croisé
Pignal ce matinl vers 7h10 c'est Stéphan
Chaban l'homme qui l'a rencontré devant
le marchand journaux l'alibi est maigre
certes mais pour les gendarmes il existe
il n'aurait pas eu d'alibi c'est pas
quelque chose que je trouvais très
importante dans dans le dossier parce
que sur les horaires vous savez on passe
pas son temps à regarder sa montre les
le témoignage visuel est quand même très
fragile les commerçants peuvent l'avir
il a pu être là et que le commerçants
s'en souviennent plus donc pour moi
c'était pas quelque chose favorable ou
défavorable qui avait de l'importance
Asier euh l'incertitude euh quant à son
aliie euh n'est pas suffisant aux yeux
des enquêteurs évidemment pour espérer
accuser HUG Pignal ou même tout
simplement le placer en garde à vue et
le confondre dans le crime qu'il tente
d'élcider alors les gendarmes laissent
donc Pignal en liberté tout en
continuant à enquêter sur lui et
rapidement ils vont se rendre compte que
depuis quelques temps ses problèmes
financiers se sont particulièrement
aggravés
en passant les comptes duc Pignal à la
loupe les gendarmes découvrent deux
informations capitales la première c'est
qu'en cette fin d'année
1996 l'homme a reçu deux sommations
d'huissier lui réclamant un total de
200000 francs c'était le 30 décembre
1996 la veille du meurtre ils apprennent
aussi que les relations entre
anne-emarie Pignal et son fils étent
devenus si tendu que celle-ci avait pour
projet de le déshériter en partie
sa
mère en avait assez des dépenses de son
fils et voulait par tout moyen essayer
de freiner ces dépenses il y avait des
tensions hein Anne-Marie Pignal qui
était une femme de
caractère extrêmement bonne gestionnaire
puisqu'elle avait en charge he la
gestion de toute cette fortune accumulée
pendant des années de
travail par le père
Pignal c'est vrai que ça c'était elle
était confrontée à un personnage qu'elle
devait considérer comme étant
irresponsable et notamment elle avait
envisagé de modifier le
testament qui était en sa faveur pour
donner une partie de sa fortune non pas
à son fils mais à ses petits enfants
ça lui l'avait appris et ça l'avait
véritablement contrarié plus incroyable
encore les enquêteurs découvrent qu'uc
Pignal a dépensé une partie importante
de l'héritage de sa mère quelques jours
peine après l'avoir
touché il avait besoin d'argent frais
donc il y a eu l'héritage qui est arrivé
et comme par hasard ces affaires qui
périclitaient euh ont commencé à aller
un petit mieux parce qu'il a un petit
peu mieux parce qu'il a remboursé un
certain nombre de choses et en
particulier il y avait ce ce squatch
dont il s'occupait à vivier du lac et
comme par hasard pratiquement du jour au
lendemain le squash n'était plus à
vendre face à ces éléments les gendarmes
pensent avoir trouvé le mobile parfait
et ils imaginent un scénario possible
acculé par ces problèmes financier HUG
aurait pris rendez-vous avec sa mère
prétextant des papiers à signer et des
cartons à déménager le 31 décembre elle
lui aurait ouvert sans se méfier et il
l'aurait
poignardé la théorie des enquêteurs
semble se tenir un détail près un détail
de poids si HUG Pignal a agressé sa mère
pour ne l'a-t-elle pas dénoncé dans
l'ambulance anne-emarie Pignal quand
elle a parlé au médecin urgentiste mais
également à son jardinier n'a jamais
cité le nom de du Pignal il lu aurait
été facile de dire que parmi les
agresseurs se trouvait son propre fils
donc on a déjà un premier élément
absolument évident c'est que la victime
elle-même ne n'accuse pas son
fils les gendarmes ne disposent d'aucune
preuve matérielle ni de témoignage
direct pendant plusieurs mois l'enquête
piétine et c'est grâce au hasard que
l'affaire va être
relancée maisi
1997 les gendarmes de chambéie entendent
un certain Philippe couvert pour une
affaire de stupéfiant affaire qui a
priori n'a rien à voir avec le meurtre
d'anne-emarie Pignal Philippe couvert
c'est un petit escroc qui déjà eu des
soucis pour vol également et il est
placé en garde à vue donc dans le cadre
de cette petite affaire et il espère
pouvoir tirer son épingle du jeu
c'est-à-dire que très vite il dit aux
enquêteurs moi j'ai des révélations à
vous faire sur l'assassinat de Madame
Pignal Philippe couvert commence par
expliquer qu'il connaît le fils de
Madame Pignal puisqu'ils ont été en
relation d'affaires Philippe couvert
connaît bien Hu Pignal pour avoir été
gérant quelques années auparavant du
club de Squad
détenu par Pignal mais Philippe couvert
explique surtout que par hasard dans un
bar il a surpris une conversation
suspecte entre HUG Pignal et un autre
homme Patrick Ballan et derrière lui il
entend il reconnaît les voix de HUG
Pignal et de Patrick Ballan deux amis à
lui Patrick Ballan disant à hupignal tu
as vu ce que tu m'as fait faire tu m'as
mis dans une galère cette dispute
avait-elle un lien avec la mort
d'anne-emarie Pignal et qui est ce
Patrick B avec qui h Pignal
s'entretenait les gendarmes n'ont jamais
entendu parler de de Patrick Ballan ils
ne savent pas qui il est évidemment ils
vont se renseigner sur lui ils
apprennent que c'est un ancien portier
de de de discothèque fort en gueule qui
aime bien aussi fréquenter les milieux
de la nuit et dépenser de dépenser de
l'argent un peu sans compter un peu à la
façon du du Pignal mais mais sans sans
le côté flamboyant que peut avoir h
Pignal à travers ses dépenses mais lors
de son interrog avec les gendarmes
Philippe couvert ne va pas s'arrêter là
il va faire des révélations beaucoup
plus directes par la suite Patrick
Ballan revirra couvert et couvert lui
demandera pourquoi il eu cette dispute
entre Hal et toi il dira mais j'étais
j'étais avec H Pignal quand quand il a
tué sa mère ce matinl et il m'a mis dans
la
galère pour la première fois depuis le
début l'enquête les gendarmes ont enfin
de quoi accuser Pignal mais peuvent-ils
se fier au témoignage de Philippe
couvert petit escroc qui semble ne pas
porter h Pignal dans son cœur dans ce
dossier on a que des personnalités qui
sortent un peu de l'ordinaire on a ce
monsieur couvert dont on sait qu'il a un
conflit très vif avec Monsieur Pignal il
se je crois qu'il se déteste et oui
puisque Pignal avait racheté le
squash donc il y avait un conflit
d'intérêt économique et ils sont connus
à donné mais vraiment ils ne s'aiment
pas s'agit-il d'une simple vengeance
entre deux concurrents Philippe couvert
accuse-il à tort les deux hommes pour le
savoir une seule solution confrontter
Ballan et
Pignal 3 juin 1997 HUG Pignal et Patrick
ballon sont convoqués à la gendarmerie
de
Chambéry interrogés les deux hommes
réfutent entièrement le récit de
Philippe couvert d'ailleurs à les en
croire ils ne se connaissent même pas
c'est vrai que pour eux il n'y a
pratiquement pas de lien entre eux ils
se connaissent pas ils se fréquentent
tout juste et face au gendarmes qui ne
savent plus qui croire h Pignal retourne
[Musique]
l'accusation hignal va même d'ailleurs
aller jusqu'à dire que Philippe couvert
est vraisemblablement le meurtrier le
bras armé qui qui a tué sa mère faute de
preuve gendarmes sont bien obligés de
laisser repartir Pignal et
Ballan donc avec le avec le magistrat
décidons de lever la la garde à vue
puisque nous n'avons pas plus d'éléments
concernant le le dossier l'affaire
l'agression de de Madame Pignal mais ils
ne vont pas baisser les bras pour autant
non seulement les deux suspects sont
placés sur écoute mais ils vont être
pris en filature et surveillé c'est
ainsi que les gendarmes vont découvrir
que Pignal Ballan qui affirma ne pas
connaître sembleutant réalité
inséparable et à partir de ce moment-là
c'est vrai que nous constatons que
Patrick Ballan et h Pignal ne se lâch
plus ils sortent ensemble régulièrement
ils partent en vacances ensemble
régulièrement
euh l'impression que le la garde à vue
les a libéré de de quelque chose voilà
al soit ils pensent qu'ils ne sont plus
surveillés soit soit la garde à vue les
a rapproché plutôt pour la première
première solution en fait les gendarmes
vont comprendre très vite que ces deux
hommesl se connaissent de longue date
mais qu'ils avaient gardé leur relation
secrète pourquoi leurent-il gardé
secrète est-ce que c'est parce que elle
est en lien avec l'assassinat
d'anne-emarie Pignal les enquêteurs à
cette époque s'interrogent encore pign
les ballons se connaissent depuis très
longtemps les gendarmes en sont
désormais persuadés mais une
subsiste pourquoi ont-ils caché leur
amitié ils obtiendront la réponse grâce
à un trè
homme les gendarmes le savent le
téléphone est l'un des moyens les plus
facile pour piéger un suspect il décide
donc de fouiller dans les relevés
téléphoniques de Patrick Ballan le
résultat ne se fait pas attendre il
concerne le jour du meurtre d'anneemarie
Pignal donc le 31 décembre 87 16 à 6h45
un appel est émis depuis le le domicile
donc de de Patrick Ballan vers un numéro
qui qui çaav être un numéro tattoo et
c'est un appareil un récepteur sur
lequel on peut recevoir un numéro de
téléphone Patrick Ballan depuis son
domicile contacte un certain Jean-Claude
hardardy il lui envoie un message sur un
récepteur tattoo comme s'il s'agissait
d'un un peu d'un réveil matin
Jean-Claude
hardardy les gendarmes se renseignent
sur ce trentenaire un ex videur de
discothèque au casier judiciaire
vierge c'est quelqu'un de de simple de
paisible de serein on décrit par
ailleurs dans le dossier comme quelqu'un
de sportif qui de la musculation c'est
vrai qu'il a la chance d'avoir un
physique costaud alors effectivement il
a pu travailler comme portier dans une
boî de nuit parce que dans le milieu
d'ex ben il y a des boîtes de nuit ce
genre d'individu parce qu'on y connait
Balan conait d'autres a pu travailler
dans ce secteur
euh il a fait plusieurs petits boulots
encore une fois sans conduite
délinquante avérée dans un premier temps
les enquêteurs décident de ne pas
interpeller cet homme ils veulent
continuer à l'observer sans qu'il ne se
doute de rien parallèlement ils
épluchent ses relevés bancaires et
apparemment Jean-Claude Hardy a des goû
de luxe ils vont s'apercevoir là que
Jean-Claude hardardy vit lui aussi un
peu au-dessus de de ses moyens notamment
il va partir en vacances aux Antilles
avec sa compagne et et aussi il dépense
de l'argent un peu sans compter en tout
cas bien au-delà de ce qu'il peut gagner
en sa qualité de de portier de nuit il a
fait deux séjours en Martinique alors
que lui-même ne travaille pas d'où
Jean-Claude Hardy tire cet argent les
enquêteurs vont découvrir quelque chose
d'étonnant l'homme reçoit régulièrement
des enveloppes de la part de Patrick
Ballan des enveloppes remplies de
billets le calcul les rapprochements et
les aveux des uns et des autres sur ce
point permettent de dire que Monsieur
Hardy aura touché entre 70 et 100000
francs de l'époque en une dizaine
d'enveloppes en espèce qu'il dépensait
au fur et à mesure pourquoi Ballan
remet-il de l'argent à Hardy et quel est
le lien entre les deux hommes et HUG
Pignal pour l'instant nous n'avons pas
de lien direct euh entre Jean-Claude
hardardy et Huc pignalal on sait qu'ils
ont des relations ensemble euh que de
l'argent passe de main en main mais on
ne sait pas qui fait quoi et à quel
moment encore une fois c'est un appel
téléphonique qui va donner un coup de
pouce aux
enquêteurs 10 août
1999 les gendarmes interceptent un appel
crucial Hardy qui se trouve chez Patrick
Ballan tente de joindre Huc Pignal mais
c'est Viviane sa femme qui décroche bien
dit qu'il faut absolument qu'il voit HUG
de toute urgence cet appel téléphonique
qui de sur cro était accompagné d'une
manipulation pour cacher le numéro est
un élément supplémentaire qui conduisait
les enquêteurs à se dire il est clair
qu'il y a une demande d'argent ou en
tout cas une attente d'argent de la part
de Monsieur Hardy en direction de Pignal
pour les gendarmes cela ne fait plus
aucun doute Hardy Ballan et Pignal sont
liés au meurtrre d'Anne-Marie Pignal
reste à déterminer comment ils n'ont
plus le choix ils vont devoir réussir à
faire parler Jean-Claude
Hardy nous sommes le 11 octobre
1999 les gendarmes savent que
Jean-Claude Hardy est venu passer le
weekend dans un hôtel du centre-ville de
Chambéry pour eux le moment est venu de
l'interpeller nous interpellons
Jean-Claude Ardy avec sa avec sa
concubine sont placés tous les deux en
garde à vue on mené la gendarmerie de
Chambéry Jean-Claude Hardy commence par
nier catégoriquement toute implication
dans le meurtre d'Anne-Marie Pignal les
enquêteurs l'interrogent alors sur les
sommes d'argent que lui a remis Patrick
Ballan et là encore il ne se démonne pas
il trouve immédiatement une
explication l'argent que me fournissait
Balan provenait d'un trafic de
drogue il va d'abord dire que ils sont
liés à un trafic de drogue on comprend
que Jean-Claude hardardy préfère
s'impliquer dans un trafic de drogue
plutôt que de dire qu'il a
éventuellement participé à un crime les
gendarmes vont alors faire écouter à
Jean-Claude Hardy l'enregistrement de
l'appel qu'il a passé à Vivien Pignal et
là Hardy comprend qu'il est
piégé il craque il nous demande à
pouvoir parler à sa sa concubine
sopieobec l'embrasser une dernière fois
donc là on se dit qu'il a des
révélations à nous faire donc
effectivement nous acceptons qu'il
puisse embrasser une dernière fois
Sophie
diobec j'écoute moi ce qu'il lui dit
manière proche il lu dit tu sais j'y
suis pour rien j'y suis pour rien et il
l'embrasse plusieurs fois et il se met à
pleurer comme elle elle ne comprend pas
et là il s'explique voici ce que
Jean-Claude Hardy explique aux
enquêteurs Patrick Ballan m'a demandé un
ou de jours avant le 31 décembre si
j'étais intéressé pour participer à un
déménagement ce jour-là il est venu me
chercher de bonne heure dans une voiture
commerciale blanche
ensuite hardardy explique que Ballan
n'était pas seul ce matinlà mais il
n'apprendra l'identité de l'inconnu que
bien plus tard Jean-Claude hardardi ne
sait pas qui l'accompagne il sait que
Patrick Ballan est dans le véhicule mais
il ne sait pas qui est l'homme qui est
derrière le volant cet homme qui est
derrière le vol c'est h
Pignal mais lui ne l'a jamais rencontré
à cette C épo là Jean-Claude hardardy
raconte qu'il est ensuite conduit par
les deux hommes vers une destination
inconnue
emmené devant une maison dans la banudex
ne connais pas les lieux Patrick Ballan
et lui-même ont attendu à l'extérieur
pendant que le 3e individu frappé à la
porte était reçu par une dame d'un
certain âge qui était venu lui
ouvrir et Monsieur Hardy nous
dit j'ai entendu des de voix ce monsieur
est rentré avec la dame à l'intérieur de
de la propriété nous sommes restés à
l'extérieur à attendre quelques instants
les éclats de voix ont perduré puis un
silence ce qui les a poussé donc à à
rentrer rapidement
dans dans la
maison mon client monsieur Hardy voit
une dame au sol avec un couteau planté
dans la poitrine s [__] je l'ai tué là
mais vous faites quoi allez on se case
et l'individu qui était à côté d'elle
disait c'est un accident c'est un
accident il faut partir il faut partir
c'est un accident et monsieur hardardy a
toujours indiqué pour moi elle était
morte elle avait les yeux
révulsés complètement inconsciente pour
moi elle était
morte donc il quitte rapidement les lieu
il remonte dans ce véhicule l'individu
reprend le volant Ballan ma mémoire
bonne place passager hardi
derrière l'individu que mon client ne
connaissait pas était énervé tapait sur
le volant en disant c'est un accident
c'est un accident personne ne va nous
croire personne ne nous a vu c'était un
accident c'était un accident bordel
c'était un
accident vous ne dites rien à personne
je crois qu'il l'aura dit je vous en
tout cas ça s'est révélé plus tard je
vous indemniserai pour votre silence au
total Jean-Claude Hardy explique avoir
touché près de 100000 francs de la part
de Pignal par l'intermédiaire de
banan les enquêteurs n'en reviennent pas
le videur vient de leur rapporter le
témoignage qu'ils attendaient depuis 2
ans les enquêteurs tiennent vraiment
c'est le vraiment le coup de théâtre
puisque les enquêteurs tiennent vraiment
une une piste sérieuse et en tout cas
suffisamment d'éléments pour inquiéter
Huc Pignal et Paris
Patrick Ballan dans les 48 heures qui
suivent les enquêteurs vont interroger
Ballan puis Pignal mais face à ces deux
hommes qui nient fermement toute
implication dans le meurtre et en
l'absence de preuve les gendarmes sont
obligés de les
libérer ils ont été remis en en liberté
par la Chambre deinstruction estimant
que ils avaient des gages de
représentation et que il pouvait
attendre en liberté que le procès
d'assise intervienne
cela va faire près de 3 ans
qu'anneemarie Pignal a été assassinée on
pense que cette histoire est terminée
mais un homme va donner une nouvelle
version des
[Musique]
faits 10 mars 2000 plusieurs mois après
son premier témoignage Ballan est de
nouveau entendu par la gendarmerie de
Chambéry et il va changer radicalement
de discours il reconnaît avoir remis des
enveloppes pleines d'argent à hardi mais
en aucun cas pour commettre un meurtre
il ne s'agit que d'un service qu'il
aurait rendu à son ami Pignal il dit que
un déménagement était prévu ce jourlà et
que lui a servi d'intermédiaire en fait
entre Huc Pignal et Jean-Claude hardardy
Jean-Claude Hardy qui était censé donner
un coup de main à H Pignal pour le
déménagement lui n'aurait fait
finalement que alert par sur son tatto
Jean-Claude Hardy pour qu'il n'oublie
pas de se rendre au rendez-vous il nit C
déplacé au côté de Jean-Claude hardardy
et duc pinal le matin du crime seulement
après vérification de ces relevés
téléphoniques cette version ne tient
pas très vite les les enquêteurs vont
vont réussir à démontrer
que Patrick Ballan ne dit pas la
vérité parce que il n'a pas reçu de coup
de fil ce matin-l de de HUG Pignal même
s'il ne donne pas les mêmes versions des
faits Jean-Claude hardardy et Patrick
Ballan sont d'accord sur point
l'implication duc Pignal dans la mort de
sa
[Musique]
mère les gendarmes pensent enfin avoir
compris ce qui s'est passé et voici leur
hypothèse la veille du meurtre le 30
décembre 1996 HUG Pignal reçoit deux
sommations d'huissier il doit 200000
francs il est ruiné et il sait qu'il va
perdre son club de
squash comme à chaque fois qu'il a
besoin d'argent il se tourne vers sa mre
il l'appelle pour prendre rendez-vous
pour le
lendemain le 31 décembre à
6h45 Patrick Ballan contacte Jean-Claude
Hardy puis le récupère devant chez lui
dans une voiture conduite par
Pignal une fois arrivé à Brison saint
Innocent HUG de sa
mère celle-ci n'attend son fils qu'une
heure plus tard elle se méfie et ouvre
un couteau à la main HUG pénètre dans la
maison il lui demande de l'argent mais
sa mère refuse de lui en
donner il se
dispute l'échange dégénère et c'est à ce
moment qu'il se saisit du couteau et la
poignarde
[Musique]
alert ses complices le
rejoignent croyant Annemarie Pignal
morte il décide de prendre la
fuite je te donner de l'argent je te
déommager je te jure je te as bien vu cé
un acdental raccompagne les de hommes
puis vers 7h10 il se rend dans le centre
d'exbain pour se construire un alibi il
achète des pains au chocolat et le
journal heureux hasard il croise son ami
Stéphan Chaban il rentre chez lui vers
8h avant de recevoir le coup de
téléphone de sa sœur 10 minutes plus
tard grâce à cette thèse des enquêteurs
h Pigna l' mis en examen pour le meurtre
de sa mère personne ne se doute alors
que l'un des témoins les plus importants
est sur le point de
[Musique]
disparaître 21 juillet 2000 sur le lac
du
Bourget ce jour-là Patrick Ballan fait
une sortie en bateau en compagnie de sa
femme et d'une
amie pendant que les deux femmes se
repose et prennent le soleil sur le
bateau lui décide curieusement de
nettoyer la coque et donc à un moment sa
femme va entendre un bruit un plouf la
femme de ballon se précipite
elle ne voit plus son mari ni sur le
bateau ni dans l'eau les heures passent
et Patrick Ballan ne réapparaît pas
monsieur Ballan a disparu dans
l'eau des recherches sont lancées
pendant plusieurs jours le fond du lac
du Bourget est inspecté mais on ne
retrouvera jamais Patrick Ballan pour
les enquêteurs il ne peut s'agir d'un
accident sur les 9 ans que j'ai
travaillé à sur chambéie chaque fois que
quelqu'un s'est noyé dans le lac du
Bourget on l'a retrouvé à part
l'hypothèse d'un malaise cardiaque
brutal
euh la noyade me semble peu plausible à
quelques mois du procès de HUG Pignal la
disparition de Patrick Ballan intrigue
se serait-il suicidé craignait-il
peut-être ce procès dans lequel il
s'apprêtait à être jugé pour complicité
d'assassinat et non assistance à
personnes en danger il va envoyer
quelques minutes avant sa disparition et
alors qu'il est déjà sur le lac un SMS à
sa maîtresse de l'époque qui pour les
enquêteurs ressemble à un sms
d'adieu est-ce que c'est un SMS de
quelqu'un qui va se suicider je n'y
crois pas davantage monsieur Ballan
n'était pas du genre à se suicider en
tout cas il se serait pas pris de cette
façonlà très vite une autre hypothèse
est évoquée aurait-on cherché à éliminer
ce témoin gênant est-ce que cette
disparition dans le lac n'est pas aussi
une disparition très opportune pour
faire bah pour faire disparaître un
témoin gênant qui aurait pu être très
important au moment du procès quelle
aurait été la couleur de ce dossier en
présence de de Monsieur Ballan qui
savait des choses Patrick Ballan et il
aurait été intéressant qu'il aille un
peu plus loin dans ce dans ses
dépositions aussitôt les regards se
tournent vers HUG Pignal celui à qui la
disparition de ballon profite le plus
les enquêteurs évidemment apprenant cela
vont s'intéresser de près à cette
mystérieuse disparition ils vont
curieusement s'apercevoir que H Pignal a
fait l'acquisition récemment d'une tenue
de plongée h Pignal aurait-il fait
disparaître son ex complice Balan cette
thèse alimente toutes les
rumeurs vérification faite à l'heure où
Patrick Ballan disparaît hucpignal est
en train de signer euh son contrôle
judiciaire euh sa présence donc euh à la
gendarmerie euh d'ex lesbin et donc il a
euh comme qui dirait un alibi en béton
pour ne pas être lié à la disparition de
Patrick Ballan dernière spéculation
celle d'une disparition volontaire
Patrick Ballan a-t-il voulu se
soustraire à la justice on s'est dit
est-ce que par hasard il aurait pas pris
la fuite c'est tout est possible dans la
vie hein elle est tout à fait plausible
parce que
euh il y a du monde sur le lac monsieur
Ballan est un homme qui est capable de
nager entre deux EOS après avoir pris
suffisamment d'air pour s'éloigner
discrètement du bateau c'est un homme
qui est capable d'être pris en charge
par un plongeur qui vient à sa rencontre
et qui lui donne un peu d'air toujours
sans ressortir à la surface c'est un
homme qui est capable de
ressortir un peu plus loin derrière un
bateau qui se trouve à proximité lequel
bateau peut s'éloigner discrètement avec
Monsieur Ballan à son bord sans que
personne ne s'en rende compte unee
hypothèse bien
entend le principal témoin a disparu et
le dossier ne contient toujours aucune
preuve matérielle à la veille du procès
l'accusation est singulièrement
fragilisée et si HUG Pignal était
innocent 27 mai 2002 c'est en homme
libre qu' Pignal se présente devant la
Cour d'assise de Chamberry et malgré la
gravité de son chef d'inculpation le
moins que l'on puisse dire c'est qu'il
semble
détendu il rentrait de Corse il était
extrêmement décontracté euh presque
arrogant et il avait un un un
comportement
assez assez étonnant pour quelqu'un qui
était accusé du du meurtre de sa mère il
avait un côté mat à Mor
ouais onit les mécaniques il était
d'ailleurs pas mal physiquement h
mais vous disez toutes les femmes sonont
follent de moi voyez c'était un un
Blur sû de lui par l'argent qu'il
avait si dans un premier temps HUG
Pignal séduit le public il va rapidement
montrer un tout autre visage notamment
lorsqu'il évoque sa
mère pour ma part ce qui m'a aussi
frappé c'est que quand il parlait de
cette de la victime il disait jamais ma
mère et encore moins maman c'était elle
tout au plus on sentait que il y avait
pas de rapport d'affection particulier
avec la victime et ça c'est ça a quand
même pesé assez lourd il me semble dans
le débat il se défendait fort bien il
cherchait surtout à convaincre les jurés
de son innocence mais sur le plan des
sentiments à l'égard de sa mère en tout
cas moi je n'en ai pas
ressenti pour Jacqueline Dufournet
l'avocate général de la cour d'assise de
Savoie HUG Pignal est un fils intéressé
qui a tué sa mère pour échapper à une
situation financière
catastrophique durant les 3 ans
d'instruction qui ont suivi la mort
d'Anne-Marie Pignal HUG a dépensé près
de 23 millions de francs soit près de 3
millions et demi
d'euros c'est vrai que j'avais beaucoup
insisté sur le côté patrimonial sur
cette haine que le fils avait à envers
sa mère qui n'attendait qu'une chose
c'était qu'elle décède pour hériter et
puis cette peur de cette vieille dame
qui en fait a peut-être pas su entourer
d'affection son fils c'est possible mais
euh qui en tout cas euh vivait dans la
terreur et c'est des éléments c'est sûr
que qui que j'ai sans doute dû mettre en
évidence dans mon réquisitoire de son
côté la défense de Pignal met en avant
l'absence de preuve et pose des
questions restées sans réponse ti pinal
avait l'intention de faire du mal à sa
mère de lui faire peur simplement parce
qu'il avait besoin de d'être accompagné
par deux
témoins autre question pourquoi
anne-emarie pignel n'a-t-elle pas
dénoncé son fils dans l'ambulance
l'accusation a son idée la victime a
peut-être voulu épargner son fils et par
là même l'honneur de la
famille peut-être qu'elle l'a reconnu et
qu'elle a pas voulu le dénoncer en tout
cas elle a parlé elle a dit qu'ils
étaient plusieurs au moins deux c'est
tout les débats progressent HUG Pignal
confiant peut-être un peu trop même s'il
n'y a pas de preuve dans un dossier il y
a ce qu'on appelle l'intime conviction
et ça dans ce dossier justement je crois
que ça a été très important parce que
Monsieur
Pignal ne s'est pas présenté devant les
jurés d'une façon très flatteuse donc il
était arrogant il était prétentieux euh
pour vous dire il était libre il allait
manger en face du palais à midi
l'audience reprenait à 2h il n'arrivait
qu'à 2h30 3h bcart donc tout le monde
l'attendait les magistrats l'attendaient
les jurés on avait l'impression qu'il se
comportait enenseigneur et maître que
tout lui était dû après 5 jours de
procès le jury se retire pour délibérer
HUG Pignal n'a aucun doute ce soir il
sera acquitté d'ailleurs HUG Pignal
avait prévu de convier une vingtaine de
personnes dans un restaurant situé de
l'autre côté sur le trottoir d'en face
de la Cour d'Assise pensant qu'il allait
sans doute fêter sa victoire devant la
Cour d'Assise 31 mai 2002 les jurés se
sont forgés leur intime conviction le
verdict tombeant être condamné à 20 ans
de prison sur un simple témoignage sans
preuve même si beaucoup d'indices
semblent vous accuser c'est ce qui est
arrivé à HUG Pignal enfant adoptif d'un
couple de riches industriel accusé
d'avoir tué sa mère adoptive dans sa h
Pignal est condamné à 20 ans de prison
un matricide qui selon le jury aurait
été commis sans
préméditation Jean-Claude hardardy pour
sa partcope d'une peine d'un an de
prison pour non assistance à personne en
danger surprise par cette décision
Viviane Pignal l'épouse de HUG est
révolté c'est inadmissible que au jour
d'aujourd'hui HUG soit condamné à 20 ans
de réclusion sur sur sur une intime
conviction et sinon sur sur des faits
des preuves tangible un an et demi plus
tard la condamnation duc Pignal sera
confirmée en appel son pourvoit en
cassation rejeté pour la justice
française h Pignal a tué sa mère
anne-mie le 31 décembre
1996 l'homme est incarcéré au centre
pénitentiaire de moulin dans l'Allier il
devrait en sortir à la fin de cette
année